okay so I was originally going to do uh
Dan slots Amazing Spider-Man Volume 2
but what I decided to do was kind of
wind the clock back a little bit instead
we're going to do a video on the origin
of antivenom now the reason why we're
doing this and it's actually kind of
like a fish out of water you know doing
the story but the reason why we're doing
this is because of the fact that there's
a there's like the third volume I think
of Dan slot Amazing Spider-Man called
The Return of antivenom and what I
didn't want to do was try to cram the
origin in with the return of antivenom
because it's like hey guys here's the
return of a character that you don't
know anything about and so it's just
kind of like well that's a problem so I
figured we'd go ahead and just kind of
like do the origin but the cool thing
about this is that this really deals in
a lot of ways with the reshuffling of
Eddie Brock and even the Spider-Man
Mythos to a degree it's really more
about Eddie Brock than Spider-Man than
Peter Parker uh but the two kind of go
hand inand in terms of why it was done
and what I mean is following the events
of of one more day when jasada sat down
and said you know we need to basically
take away everything that dates Peter
Parker that is to say everything that
makes him anything other than just like
a kid trying to find his way in the
world uh fans freaked and they they
freaked for the same reason that you
know the pre new52 Wally West
disappeared things like that you know
when when fans latch on to a character
they don't really like to see them
change but more so than that a lot of
people grew up with like the Peter
Parker Mary Jane Watson relationship and
to suddenly see all that just tossed
away because Peter Parker sold a sold to
the devil so Aunt May could live for
another 10 years really seemed just
weird and people just didn't like that
at all it was one of the most really
reviled Spider-Man stories in the
history of his character's publication
history if not in the history of comics
in general and so the result was that
Spider-Man fans and media so on and so
forth everybody just kind of ran Jay
Michael shinski off the title and the
result was that the Spider-Man uh the
Spider-Man Publications were basically
run by a team of people it was like
jasad you know kind of throwing his
hands in the air and saying who wants
the write Spider-Man and everybody was
like well I do and so he was like then
all of you guys come over here and we'll
all just write stories and this is where
Dan slot initially kind of got a start
it's really not until big time that Dan
slot officially took over the Spider-Man
title on his own but the fact remains
here that with this whole reshuffling of
the Peter Parker Mythos there were a lot
of things that were being introduce a
lot of things that were being done and
that's kind of the beauty the benefit of
this story is yeah it is in the middle
of everything but it's in the middle of
of everything before anything's fleshed
out and so a lot of the characters that
we're going to see popping up here
haven't really had their origin stories
explained yet that didn't come you know
for another 10 15 20 issues after this
particular publication uh but the fact
remains here that with uh with with
Peter Parker you know picking up with
him the cool thing is that we kind of
get this you know reminder of everything
that's going on and that's what I wanted
to touch on for a second so you know the
whole origin of Peter Parker's Timeless
you know a kid who's a science geek
bitten by a radioactive spider gets the
proportional strength of a spider he has
spider s so on and so forth Spider-Man
is born becomes a hero after the death
of Uncle Ben all that kind of good stuff
but the idea is that there are also some
characters that are being introduced you
know you have like Menace for example
you have Mr negative one half of a split
personality between a guy named Martin
Lee and uh well really a guy posing as
Martin Lee and and Mr negative you have
a few characters who are being
introduced here and there of course
you've got your regular cast so you have
like uh Harry Osborne so on and so forth
but what this does is it initially picks
up with a conflict between Menace and
Spider-Man now this is one of the things
that I was talking about where we're
kind of in the middle of things but none
of this has really been fleshed out
Menace is a character who popped up
before this story happened but the
origin of Menace had never really been
explored that didn't happen until
Amazing Spider-Man 586 I think and it
turns out to be somebody that we're
quite familiar with but the idea here is
that Menace is in a lot of ways kind of
this reimagining of the Green Goblin
right I mean you know Norman Osborne is
like a like an intrinsic villain of
Spider-Man the idea here is that Menace
is really seems to be acting more like a
vigilante you know in the sense that
Menace doesn't really have an adherence
to like one particular person it's just
Menace kind of pops up and says here are
the things that I'm about you know about
taking out Spider-Man so on and so forth
but it's kind of this reminder where
things stand at the same time uh there
were also a lot of refugees who seem to
have been brought into the United States
for reasons that we're not really sure
about and they're just kind of escaping
taking up residents they'll actually
kind of wrap back around towards the end
of the story but again this is just kind
of a reminder of the direction of things
you're going in in terms of Peter Parker
where he stands what he's about but this
is when we start to get into the idea of
front line now uh prior to this A guy by
the name of Dexter Bennett had basically
purchased the Daily Bugle the problem
with this is that instead of upholding
the traditions of J Jonah Jameson by
keeping the Daily Bugle as a reputable
news source albeit a reputable news
source that's slanted against Spider-Man
the fact remains that Dexter Bennett
basically turned it into a tabloid
magazine it was like the national
Inquirer the weekly world news it was
the the lowest of any form of
publication and because of what because
of that uh Peter Parker effectively left
now it was really more of like I guess a
firing than him actual actually leaving
and the reason why was because of the
fact that under you know the the
leadership of Dexter Bennett Peter
Parker was basically transformed into a
member of the paparazzi but his actions
in taking photographs of people albeit
not really wanting to do so led to the
deaths of one of the people that he was
photographing and so following that
realizing that his action was leading to
the death of people he basically vacated
now prior to this Robbie Robertson had
left Sally Floyd Ben urick they had all
taken off to form Frontline now of
course Frontline is a is a name you guys
are probably familiar with with regards
to Civil War you know initially started
out as a Blog but it was transformed
into a wholesale News company uh
following the conclusion of Civil War
and what's also going on here is a front
line itself you know kind of picking up
where jjon and Jameson's Daily Bugle
left off after it was bought by uh by
Dexter Bennett you know by considering
itself to be a reputable news source
it's not focusing on the glitz and
glamour tabloid stuff and focusing on
actual important stories up front line
is focusing on a guy by the name of
Randall Crown now the reason why they're
focusing on Randall Crown is because
he's a mayoral candidate but the idea
here is that he is involved in these
individuals you know that Spider-Man was
dealing with those individuals who were
running off in the fight all of whom
appear to have been trafficked into the
United States and so the idea is that
Randall Crown is working with some third
party we don't really know what it is
but he's working with some individual to
traffic humans into the US for whatever
the reason happens to be but what we end
up doing is we basically pick up with
with Norman Osborne's Thunderbolts now
this is when we start to get into the
aftermath of Civil War I mean we've done
secret Invasion right like we talked
about the secret Invasion event you can
find that down in the description of
this video but secret Invasion basically
dealt with the aftermath you know
following the death of Captain America
you know following the main Civil War
event itself it was kind of Marvel
bringing to a close this whole idea of
the Superhuman registration act and
Secret Invasion concluded with Tony
Stark being ousted as director of shield
and Norman Osborne taking his place and
so because Norman Osborne took his place
Norman Osborne disbanded Shield put
hammer in its place and basically used
the Thunderbolts as a way for him to
begin going through and carrying out his
own individual campaigns now I know a
lot of you guys are probably asking
about Eddie Brock a lot of you guys want
to know what's going on with Eddie Brock
and so what we do is we transition to a
place called feast and feast is
basically uh it really stands for the
idea of a food emergency aid shelter and
train this run by this guy named Mr Lee
for the purpose of grabbing individuals
who are homeless who have been displaced
whatever the case may be and giving them
the tools they need to get back on their
feet and to find success and so what
happens is I guess we basically find out
that Aunt May is volunteering at this
facility but the entire basis behind uh
this this introduction comes by way of
Betty brand now of course the cool thing
about Betty brand is she's a longtime
member of the Spider-Man Mythos I mean
she goes back you know a long long long
time and in fact she was the first
romantic interest of Peter Parker before
Gwen Stacy I don't think it was really
shortlived it was really more of you
know marvel kind of uh kind of toying
around with the idea before Gwen Stacy
and Peter got together but she's here
because of the fact that Dexter Bennett
basically says look I'm a supporter of
Randall Crown all right this newspaper
is basically going to serve as the media
arm of Randall Crown we're going to do
everything we can to get him elected if
there's a publication out there that's
posting information that basically
contradicts the idea that Randle Crown
is the best candidate then your job
Betty brand is to go find information to
discredit those individuals in this
instance Bill Hollister Bill Hollister
is a guy who's basically running against
uh Randall crown and what Dexter Bennett
says is go find a guy named Martin Lee
he's basically helping to fund the
campaign of Bill Hollister your job is
to report on him and to find dirt on
that guy so we can use that to discredit
Bill Hollister we can say you know well
Bill Hollister is being funded by a
criminal he's being funded by a guy
who's involved in trafficking whatever
the case may be find information so that
we can use it to discredit Hollister and
so with Betty brand showing up here at
the uh at the feast facility this is
when we pick up with Eddie Brock now the
reason why I I kind of waited until this
point to talk about this because I know
a lot of you guys are kind of like
there's was a lot there was a lot going
on with Eddie Brock yes there was what
Marvel did is with uh I think it was
spectacular Spider-Man Volume 2 the
first five issues composed a story
called the hunger and what he basically
said is where the original introduction
of Venom established that uh that Eddie
Brock was a guy whose career was
basically ruined by Peter Parker or by
Spider-Man and he bonded with the venom
symbiot for Retribution what Marvel does
is they came back and said no that's not
really the case instead what happened
was Eddie Brock had cancer and the Venom
symbiot bonded itself to Eddie Brock uh
just for the simple fact that Eddie
Brock's body was just pumping out
chemicals like crazy and it would keep
the Venom symbiot going and so in
response to that every time Eddie Brock
uh went after Spider-Man every time the
two of them got into a conflict Eddie
Brock was acting on the defensive he was
terrified that if Spider-Man took the
Venom symbiot away from him it would
result in him dying now eventually what
Marvel did is they came back between
2004 and 2007 and they started launching
all these small little stories about
Eddie Brock through about two or three
of them and what happened is Eddie Brock
basically cast off the symbiot uh itself
he came to terms with the idea that he
was going to die and this basically
picked up with him succumbing to his
cancer at least appearing to succumb to
his cancer and falling into the process
of dying now again this ties into the
idea that Marvel was moving the Venom
symbiot away from Eddie and putting it
on on Scorpion but what happens is Eddie
Brock basically travels to the feast
facility he meets with Mr Lee and Mr Lee
basically cures him now this is the
other half of the Mr negative Persona so
one of the reasons why I kind of wanted
to wait to this point to cover that but
the whole Mr negative Mr Lee dichotomy
is is kind of strange that's fleshed out
in a different origin we don't really
need to know too much about him not for
this story anyway the only thing we
really need to know is that Mr Lee uh
the actual person that we're seeing here
is a guy that can heal people by
touching them when it comes to Mr
negative he's the other side of the coin
it's like this dichotomy between good
and evil Bruce Banner The Incredible
Hulk that kind of thing you know it's
this Dr Jackal Mr Hyde sort of situation
the face that we see here with Mr Lee is
the good side but at this point the way
that Marvel's played this out he doesn't
know about the Mr negative Persona he
just kind of switches over to it and
then Mr negative basically operates as a
Crime Boss in Chinatown but what happens
is that where Mr Lee had essentially
touched Eddie Brock and cured him of his
cancer in this instance when Mr Lee's
talking to Betty Brandt and he's
basically talking about how this place
is considered to be a place of Miracles
but how it's really you know God curing
people so on and so forth when he
touches Eddie Brock a second time it
reactivates the latent symbiot uh Venom
symbiot in his body now what this does
is this basically sets the stage for the
introduction of anti venom for the idea
of Eddie Brock going from normal Eddie
Brock to becoming antivenom and the way
this is is actually really really cool
it's one of these interesting things
where it's like a million different
things all going on at the same time but
with Peter Parker heading back you know
going back to his uh going back to his
residence he's encountered by Norman
Osborne now the reason why is because at
this moment right now Spider-Man's
essentially a fugitive and the reason
why Spider-Man's a fugitive is because
Norman Osborne with all his power all
his ability has been trying to find a
way to bring Spider-Man down the problem
with this is that Spider-Man is an
Avenger Spider-Man is one of the world's
most celebrated Heroes the other thing
you have to keep in mind here is that
following the events of one more day and
I think during the events of brand new
day I'm not going to swear to that Peter
Parker went to doctor strange and had
Doctor Strange wipe the world's mind
that Peter Parker was Spider-Man of
course he revealed his identity during
Civil War that's why no one knows who he
is because Doctor Strange took care of
that for him and so the result is that
Norman Osborne all he really knows is
that Peter Parker gets pictures of
Spider-Man the two of them seem to work
together and he wants to know where
Spider-Man is that's why Spider-Man's
being frame because Norman Osborne
basically wants to make Spider-Man look
like a murderer by going around killing
people and then putting spider you know
spider tracker devices on these dead
bodies so that anybody who covers a
story any forensic you know scientist
whoever it is that analyzes these bodies
will come to the conclusion that
Spider-Man killed them now of course we
know Spider-Man didn't but what this
does is it allows Norman Osborne to kind
of you know show up in uh in New York
show up in Manhattan and begin the
process of trying to find Peter Parker
now with Norman Osborne basically being
forced to vacate the apartment because
of the fact that you know the the
roommate of Peter Parker who at the time
was a cop uh was basically showing up
because of the fact that Norman Osborne
didn't want to be seen as somebody who
was who was you know caught abusing his
power because likely it would lead to
him being removed as director of Shield
what ended up happening here is he
basically takes off and then Peter
Parker as Spider-Man goes to see him in
his base of operations more or less to
to question him to interrogate him to
find out what it is he's doing because
keep in mind while Norman Osborne
doesn't know that Peter Parker's
Spider-Man Peter Parker knows that
Norman Osborne is the Green Goblin and
where Norman Osborne is putting on the
front that he's a legit Guy where he's
putting on the front of the world that
he's a capable director of Shield or I
guess the director of hammer at this
point Peter Parker knows this only a
matter of time before his you know
nefarious Deeds come to light and so
Peter Parker's half waiting it out half
looking for information to verify that
Norman Osborne's a bad guy because of
course you know we know that he is but
what Norman Osborne had also done is in
response to the idea that he had to
leave Peter Parker's apartment early he
sent the rest of his Thunderbolts Out
song Bird Venom so on and so forth sent
them all out and basically said go find
Spider-Man do whatever you need to do
but go find Spider-Man of course not
realizing the Spider-Man was going to
show up on his doorstep but what
happened is the Venom Sy symet was
basically tracking down its previous
host you know tracking down the last
host that it had the issue with this is
that one thing to keep in mind the venom
symbiot has a mind of its own in a lot
of ways not only that um you know Matt
gargan doesn't really know how to use it
effectively he's still relatively new to
the whole Venom concept and so he's not
nearly as Adept or as used to Venom as
uh as Eddie Brock is and the result is
that the Venom symbiot is actually
tracking down or at least it seems like
it's tracking down Eddie Brock and the
reason why is because what it does is it
smashes into the feast facility and
encounters Eddie Brock with the
intention of remerging with him the
issue with this is that when the Phenom
symbiot accesses his body it jumpstarts
this latent you know symbiot uh these
symbat cells inside the body of of Eddie
Brock and what he does is he emerges as
antivenom now with regards to Marvel
creating this uh this standard they had
to find a way to differentiate the two
right I mean all the Symbiotes have some
aspect of them that make them make them
unique whether it's toxin basically the
child of Carnage whether it is uh you
know Venom itself whether it is Carnage
itself whatever the case may be a lot
lot of the Symbiotes have things that
make them different that make them
unique they they share a lot of common
traits the immunity to Spider-Man Spider
Sense you know the the same sort of
abilities the Spider-Man has wall
crawling shooting webs so on and so
forth for antivenom he's basically a guy
or at least the powers that that
antivenom has are almost like a like a
healing touch so to speak in the sense
that you know the abilities of Martin
Lee were absorbed to some capacity or in
some form or fashion but what antivenom
has the ability to do is to basically
touch the bodies of other people and
cleanse them of impurities and what this
does is it gives Venom a weakness to
antivenom in the form that whenever
Eddie Brock touches the Venom symbient
the Venom symbiot will start to recoil
it will start to to sort of go away
because of the fact that it's literally
being burned it's like putting fire to
your skin and so what happens is
Spider-Man of course shows up on the
scene realizing that the you know that
Venom's basically shown up at the feast
facility where Aunt May works and it's
just like this three-way battle between
the two and it's actually really kind of
cool to see it's like Spider-Man versus
antivenom versus Venom and it's awesome
I love I love things like this I love
the way these events uh you know kind of
kind of coales the way these little
stories uh coales and and begin to come
together but in the midst of this whole
conflict in the midst of all this
madness we suddenly have the Menace
arriving now of course with the Menace
showing up here it's really for the
purpose of of grabbing Bill Hollister
carrying out his own goals carrying out
his own means and so what we do is while
you know Menace basically takes off with
Bill Hollister or at least it seems like
Menace is taking off with Bill Hollister
we have Spider-Man you know Peter Parker
of course planting his camera for the
purpose of taking pictures so he can
give them to Frontline and then engaging
in the conflict the funny thing about is
this kind of like a mistake of identity
right I mean Peter Parker comes to
realize that antivenom is Eddie Brock
but in his mind Eddie Brock is a bad guy
you know if Eddie Brock is wearing a
symbient then it means Eddie Brock's
going to go do bad stuff and this is a
huge deal because yeah Cletus Cassidy
was dangerous you know but Eddie Brock
knows how to fight Spider-Man in a way
Carnage may never know now of course
they're both equally dangerous and and
and in truth I would go as far as to say
that if if we're talking about a direct
fight Peter Parker going against Carnage
Peter Parker going going against Venom
it might be kind of a tough cell to tell
me that Venom might get the upper hand
that in the end Carnage would be
probably be the one to come out on top
but the idea here is that Peter Parker
basically says look you know if you're
Eddie Brock then you must be a bad guy
but you're fighting Venom so are you a
bad guy is Peter Parker trying to get
his bearings trying to understand what's
going on but while this is happening
kind of staying out of the way at the
same time and so a really funny moment
uh ends up happening here you know when
Peter Parker takes this philosophy the
enemy of my enemy is my friend when he
tells you know antivenom he's like hey
you hate Venom right and anti Venom's
like yeah and he's like well I hate him
too let's team up and then they
basically team up again Venom and and
start taking him out and it's really
cool to see it's it's it's really fun to
see but the issue with this is that you
know when uh when Mt gargan is basically
cured or at least it seems like he's
cured of this Venom symbia where it's
basically removed from his body
antivenom basically turns his sights to
uh to Peter Parker now the funny thing
about this is he says look I can sense
that you that you have issues that that
your your blood is not as pure as it
needs to be part of this is because of
the fact that at some point along the
line you were exposed to Radioactive man
so you've got a little bit of radiation
in your blood but then he also realizes
oh you've got a lot of radiation in your
blood now we know that that's how Peter
Parker's Powers function you know Peter
Parker has his abilities because his
blood is a radiated and so if antivenom
were to be able to go through with what
it is that he's doing right now which is
basically purging the radiation from the
blood of Peter Parker he would lose all
of his spider powers and so it's kind of
cool seeing this whole thing go on the
problem with this is that while all
these events are unfolding of course
when the cops had shown up when Menace
was trying to take Bill Hollister and
Menace was forced to leave Bill
Hollister behind that Menace comes
across Norman Osborne now this is cool
because this is kind of of this return
to familiarity with Norman Osborne right
like there are moments in his
character's publication history that are
iconic for example the death of the
Green Goblin when uh when Harry I almost
said when Harry Potter when Norman
Osborne and Peter Parker fought
following the night gwy Stacy died that
it resulted in uh really in Norman
Osborne falling on his own sword you
know being impaled by his own glider uh
in a lot of ways this Bears some
Hallmarks to that particular fight in
the sense that Menace is using the
various devices of Norman Osborne Menace
is you know facing off against him and
the fight's very similar to the conflict
between the two and even Menace you know
Menace itself references the instance
where Norman Osborne basically died
against Peter Parker and says hey look
you were impaled on your own glider
before let's see if we can do it again
now in the middle of this whole conflict
with uh you know between Peter Parker
and antivenom the forces of the
Thunderbolts arrive on the scene and the
reason why is because of the fact that
Norman Osborne is like look guys we got
to go we got to bail the authorities are
moving in here we're making too much of
a scene we're supposed to be operating
behind the scenes No one's supposed to
know that my hand is here no one's
supposed to catch my hand in the cookie
jar so he says in order to keep that
from happening we got to bail out so he
says grab Matt gargan we'll get him out
of here you know and of course the idea
is grab Peter Parker or grab Spider-Man
if you can as well of course they're not
able to and Peter Parker essentially
makes his Escape at the same time it's
Marvel setting the stage for the uh the
whole events the the whole situation
with the future of antivenom in the
sense that antivenom kind of sits down
for a second and says okay Spider-Man
took off I can go after Spider-Man or I
can go after Venom what anti venom says
is I'm going to pursue Venom my goal is
going to be to take him out and remove
remove the last vestiges of the Venom
symbia those little cells or what have
you from the body of of of Scorpion
basically removing his ability to become
venom and so because of this with
everything kind of wrapping up you know
Peter Parker travels back checks on his
a May makes sure that everything's all
right but then we also have uh Norman
Osborne speaking directly to uh to
Randall crown and what we find out is
that Norman Osborne and Randall Crown
were essentially working together in the
sense that Randle Crown was was uh was
trafficking people into the US by way of
the various you know cargo ships and so
on and so forth that belonged to Norman
Osborne of course this was really you
know kind of a big deal it a very hush
hush theme for Osborne just because of
the fact that if it came to light that
he was complicit in the trafficking of
humans it would bring down everything
that he's worked so hard for because
remember what Norman Osborne's trying to
do is basically take over the United
States and so what he does is he grabs
the camera that Peter Parker had
basically left behind you know
forgetting that it was there and he
starts showing the photos to the members
of the Thunderbolts and he says there's
a weakness here there's a weakness here
that we can exploit and what he does is
he says whenever this this camera is
posted up it's basically whoever the
whoever Spider-Man is getting pictures
for himself and what he says is that
inside the suit on the spider is
basically a tracking device and the
camera follows the spider suit which is
how it is that it's always able to get
these perfect shots that's why the
camera is just not taking shots of an
empty road you know it is it's actually
following his physical body and that's
why he's always got his chest or his
suit turned out to the camera so we can
take pictures of him while he's moving
but what Norman Osborne says is what we
can do is we Bas we can basically tap
into the frequency that this camera uses
to follow the device in his chest and we
can in turn find a way to basically
infiltrate Spider-Man spider to
basically deceive it so he doesn't know
that we're there we can use that you
know to our own advantage and then we
can take him out from Close Quarters
from a distance we can shoot him while
he's going from building to building and
a Spider Sense will not alert him to
what it is that's about to happen now
from here we find out that among the
various soldiers that exist as part of
uh Norman Osborne's regime is actually
antivenom it's Eddie Brock and this is
when we learn that his suit basically
allows him to shape shift it allows him
to take on virtually any form that he
wants to and the result is that he's
essentially infiltrating this and the
cool thing is that again Eddie Brock is
antivenom you know is kind of like a
it's trying to be a hero he's trying to
be a good guy and that's one of the
things that makes him so unique the
problem with this is that after the
story I don't think he shows up again
until the return of anti venom so it's
kind of sad to see him only show up for
a handful of comics but the idea here is
that he's essentially keeping tabs on
everything that's going on monitoring
everything that's taking place now with
regards to Matt gargan with regards to
scorpion basically losing his ability to
become venom it's not like the Venom SYM
it's gone from his body in its entirety
it's still there the issue is that it's
basically been damaged to the point that
it almost seems to be Beyond repair and
so what happens is a radioactive man
basically begins to expose the body of
Matt gargan to radioactivity and the
reason why is because the goal is to
basically take a blood sample and see if
there's a way to essentially remove the
antibodies basically that antivenom puts
out to remove those from the body of uh
of of Matt gargon and so what happens is
Norman Osborne actually takes these
chemicals and uses them on a guy named
freak now freak was originally
introduced as a drug addict in The
Amazing Spider-Man story that's really
all he was he's a character that was
created as a means to an end and what I
mean by that is he appeared in a couple
stories here and there but this is by
far the most notable role he played
freak was basically a guy who grabbed
just a random suring injected himself
with the chemicals from Kurt Connors
from the lizard's lab and then suddenly
he developed the ability to basically
adapt to any situation he's not you know
he's not like a mutant or anything and
it's not an instantaneous thing instead
what happens is you know he'll be burned
alive for example and then his body will
enter a Crysis stage and he'll come out
immune to Fire and that's the way his
body functions it gets to the point
where he just basically is immortal like
he can't be killed and that's what
Norman Osborne's banking on here what he
does is he takes the antivenom compound
the antivenom compound he injects it
into the body of freak with the
intention of creating this super Venom
and the purpose of having the super
Venom will basically be to kind of lay
waste to things you know that's the
danger of it is that a few drops will
ultimately end up killing people and so
what happens is Norman Osborne basically
goes back to his lab for the purpose of
using the this chemical to to engineer
it modify it a bit and then jump start
the powers of of Matt gargon allowing
him to become venom again the funny
thing about this though is this is kind
of like this Resurgence of the Green
Goblin not perfectly not in the sense
that like the Green Goblin has been gone
forever the Green Goblin's been around
but this is just another instance where
he shows up it's another instance of
this sort of split situation in the mind
and the body of uh of of Norman Osborne
now from here it's also you know again
Bullseye and the various members of the
Thunderbolts carrying out the mission of
of Norman osor basically sping Peter
Parker because or at least fighing
Spider-Man because again they're
basically using the the frequency that
the camera uses to uh to access his
device in his chest to tap into his
location they basically use it like a
homing device and that's exactly what
they do you have Bullseye you have a
handful of soldiers that locate
Spider-Man and track him down the
problem with this is that in the midst
of their efforts to take out Spider-Man
the entire group is suddenly met with
the arrival of antivenom and this is
cool because antivenom basically takes
all these guys out and it's interesting
to see these two guys pair up because it
turns into an actual team up but it
starts as like a weird situation that
Spider-Man just doesn't really know how
to work his mind around I mean he's used
to Eddie Brock being a bad guy he's used
to Eddie Brock only working alongside
him in certain situations for example
the emergence of Carnage and so because
of that the two of them actually working
alongside you know working side by side
as Heroes the idea of uh of of antivenom
saying hey look you left your camera
behind they took it and that's how they
found you you know it's interesting it's
sort of a weird situation for Peter
Parker and so ultimately what happens is
antivenom and Parker are able to to
basically take out these various
soldiers knock out bullseye and then
just bail out now of course we also have
Matt gargan being injected with the
serum the issue is that it's not an
instantaneous thing it'll take time for
the Venom symbiot to come back and the
reason why is because the purpose of the
serum is to basically burn out the
antivenom antibodies and allow the Venom
symbiot to begin reemerging and so while
it's in the process of doing that uh
scorpion is basically given an updated
scorpion suit and so again this is
Marvel kind of toying this is Marvel
going back and forth saying hey guys you
know you're getting the best of both
you're basically getting a side by-side
comparison here's a story where you see
the Scorpion and you see the Scorpion as
Venom in the exact same situations in
the exact same conflicts which one do
you like more is really kind of what was
going on here and so the result is that
we you know we really get to kind of
choose which one we enjoy which one we
don't enjoy and so uh picking up with
Spider-Man and picking up with antivenom
the idea here is antivenom basically
says hey look Norman Osborne the
Thunderbolts the guys you're looking for
they all went back to uh to to the
Osborne lab they're all back there you
need to go to the Osborne research group
if you want to track him down and so it
was kind of cool seeing these two guys
work together but we also see some
really cool bit of Ingenuity the reason
why this works so well and the reason
why team ups between Venom and
Spider-Man have always worked is because
it's like they're two sides of the same
coin you got Spider-Man with his spider
sense you know with his capabilities his
agility strength so on and so forth and
you've got Eddie Brock with his
experience as part of Venom you know
with the Venom symbient and so because
of that we basically have you know what
looks like Spider-Man infiltrating the
facility and being attacked by the
Thunderbolts only for us to find out
that's not Spider-Man that's actually
antivenom shapes shifted as Spider-Man
and so it's cool to see these these
things go against each other it's cool
to see them function and so what happens
is of course you know Green Goblin makes
his presence known he and Spider-Man
fight for a little while is kind of
wrapping these things up by giving us a
bit of fan service in terms of the the
characters you know fighting against one
another but we also find out that a lot
of these people that have been brought
in a lot of these humans that have been
trafficked that have been kidnapped were
being experimented on and so the
question is okay you know where's this
road going to lead now we're actually
not going to find that out we're not
going to find out here uh where this
road leads instead what we do is we
basically pick up with uh with scorpion
you know again continuing to fight
against uh against antivenom and then
actually injecting him with a Barb that
basically seems to take away Eddie Brock
AB ility to be Venom and so during the
entirety of this conflict Norman Osborne
had essentially activated a
self-destruct in the building with the
idea that the entire building was going
to come crashing down that everybody was
going to be killed Spider-Man was going
to die you know of course freak still in
that building was going to die we know
they made it out but in the end it's
this idea that that we're kind of left
with a few unanswered questions in the
sense of these individuals who are being
experimented on so on and so forth but
we're also left with the idea of
antivenom you know kind of focusing on
Eddie Brock himself in the end he just
sort of says hey look you know life gave
me a second chance life gave me the
opportunity to to go forward and be a
hero the question is what am I going to
do with this heroic role what am I going
to do with this with this situation and
so what he does he basically you know
his suit reactivates he starts walking
around shapeshifting and then we again
we don't really find out too much about
what happens with him I think he does
you know a couple things here and there
but aside from that as far as I'm aware
he doesn't really come back until the
return of Venom storyline is part of Dan
slot's Amazing Spider-Man but if you
guys are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and
yeah kind of a lengthy video I will
catch you guys later peace